[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans
auditions publiques l'émission politique
communale LCP et Public Sénat une heure
en invité ce soir notre invité c'est
Jean-Philippe Tanguy bonsoir à vous
bonsoir député RN de la somme vous avez
37 ans sauf erreur vous allez bientôt
fêter non pas votre anniversaire quoi
que je n'en sais rien mais surtout votre
première année à l'Assemblée on se
souvient qu'en juin 2022 le
rassemblement national entrait en force
à l'Assemblée avec 89 députés il y en a
88 un an après et justement un an plus
tard et bien plusieurs sondages semble
valider la stratégie de normalisation
avec Marine Le Pen en chef de groupe
mais reste un obstacle semble-t-il si
votre isolement qui demeure au Palais
Bourbon dans votre marche vers l'Elysée
puisque Marine Le Pen devrait être
candidate comment surmonter cet obstacle
dans l'actualité nationale que nous
allons aborder avec vous Emmanuel Macron
à Marseille pour trois jours ça lui et
vous les investissements pourriez vous
fait de différents le partage de la
valeur vous lui par le gouvernement pour
augmenter le pouvoir d'achat Gérald
Darmanin en Guyane le futur texte sur
l'immigration les coups de boutois de
Eric Zemmour pas plus tard que samedi
dernier contre le RN la grève au JDD
voilà Journal du Dimanche quelques-uns
des sujets qui vont être abordés par
Brigitte boucher tamtrane nuit également
par Vincent roux et puis Yves réars vous
interpellera sur votre stratégie
politique et enfin vous avez accepté on
vous en remercie de débattre avec Bruno
Milian député MoDem vous parlerez
notamment des zones à faible émission
pour voulier les supprimer est-ce que
c'est toujours le cas lui en tout cas
les défenses vous lui répondrez tout à
l'heure quelques questions d'abord pour
commencer avec vous sur l'actualité la
plus j'allais dire la plus brûlante de
ces dernières heures c'est ce qui s'est
passé en Russie 24 heures critique avec
une tentative de mutinerie du patron de
Wagner si on se place du point de vue de
Poutine qui a porté finalement le coup
territoire le plus important au Kremlin
l'OTAN ou Prigogine
je vais vous dire moi je pense que c'est
Vladimir Poutine lui-même qui s'est mis
un coup de boudoir en organisant depuis
des années ou en laissant organiser en
tout cas cette milice intérieure cette
véritable armée par étatique faite au
début de tout ce que la Russie pouvait
compter de voyou autour d'un voyou
monsieur brigolin et d'abord pour faire
des opérations on va dire interlope en
Afrique contre les souvent d'ailleurs
les intérêts français mais aussi contre
les démocraties parfois et souvent
malheureusement fragile notamment dans
le sel et en zone subsaharienne ce qui
avait d'ailleurs conduit notre Assemblée
a déclaré le mouvement Wagner comme
mouvement terroriste et nous avions
soutenu cette dénomination donc comme
disait vous savez Machiavel en son temps
il conseillait au prince aux dirigeants
de ne pas entretenir de mercenaires
d'armée privée de cours d'eau tiède
voilà bon donc quand vous connaissez
classique mais donc Vladimir Poutine qui
a sucé suscité l'admiration de Marine Le
Pen à une époque a creusé sa tombe ouais
en tout cas à faire en sorte que
ce cette milice privée armée le
concurrent le rivalisme et peut-être le
déstabilise soit évidemment un état dans
l'état dans une journée qui a apprécié
qui a évidemment fait peur au monde
entier pourquoi parce que la Sylvie
n'est pas tant la pérennité de l'admire
Poutine lui-même dont on le sort en soi
peu d'intérêt appartient au peuple russe
mais c'est la structure de l'État russe
du régime qui nous semble extrêmement
fragile on sait toujours pensé que
l'agressivité irrationnelle du régime
russe et qui la conduite
lui-même qui l'a conduit à cette
invasion illégale et légitime et
criminelle de l'Ukraine était lié à la
fragilité de son régime de son régime
lui-même et je pense que la Russie est
un
ours au pied d'argile si je puis dire un
colosse au pied d'argile et que il se
l'effondrement de de du régime russe
pour être extrêmement dangereux
puisqu'on parle d'un régime qui possède
plus de 4000 aux grives nucléaires qui
contrôlent un territoire immense qui
territoire dont les richesses naturelles
pardon sont l'objet de convoitise en
particulier de la Chine vous avez parlé
de l'agression de l'Ukraine Georgia Méli
qui est président du Conseil italien
soutient j'allais dire presque sans
réserve l'Ukraine par exemple les
livraisons d'armes pour elle il y a
aucun problème pourquoi est-ce que le
rassemblement national qui est de la
même famille politique que l'extrême
droite italienne n'est pas sur la même
ligne madame Meloni a appartenu à partir
pardon à une famille politique a
toujours été beaucoup plus atlantiste
par Monsieur Berlusconi et la droite
italienne et la coalition dont faisait
partie à l'époque le parti de Madame
Meloni avait soutenu par exemple
invasion de l'Irak à part les États-Unis
donc bon ça a toujours été une force
beaucoup plus atlantiste nous notre
position elle est simple c'est que la
France doit avoir une diplomatie au sein
du camp occidental différente pour être
capable de parler à des puissances non
alignées ou hostiles la Russie la Chine
et aujourd'hui vous dites que l'Ukraine
est agressé vous l'avez vous-même dit
comportement irrationnel de Vladimir
Poutine si vous poussez la logique de
cette analyse que vous faites vous aider
l'Ukraine à vaincre la Russie en Libye
en lui livrant des hommes alors savons
toujours soutenu la possibilité de
l'aider financièrement par des moyens de
défense en accueillant évidemment les
réfugiés nous pensons que si nous
livrons et nous pensons toujours des
armes offensives la France s'aligne sur
toutes les démocraties et ses alliés
occidentales et nous ne pouvons pas
jouer un rôle dans la résolution
diplomatique les militaires il y a des
armes elles ne sont pas ni offensives ni
défensives via des armes peut-être
trancher mais pas les diplomates
aujourd'hui la résolution diplomatique
du conflit en Ukraine et délégué soit la
Turquie soit à la Chine et aujourd'hui
aucun démocratie membre du Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU namaya partir dans la
résolution diplomatique de ce conflit
ils peuvent avoir des applications très
graves puisque c'est le seul européen et
le fait qu'aucune grande démocratie
puissance européenne ne soit capable de
parler
à la Russie et à l'Ukraine non pas pour
favoriser l'un ou l'autre mais pour
arriver à libérer l'Ukraine de
l'invasion et à trouver les moyens de la
paix pose problème car ni la Turquie ni
la Chine ne sont des démocraties donc
pas de soutien pas de livraison comme
Georgia melonial Ukraine question sympa
pardon parce que on répond simplement à
cette question quelle
qu'on soit pardon la Crimée russe ou pas
l'histoire de la Crimée et russe est-ce
que la Crimée est russe est russe au
regard du droit international
ou est-ce qu'elle est ukrainienne était
le peuple criminé
est-elle à la Russie oui mais ça ne veut
pas dire que la résolution
elle n'est pas Madame Martichoux que les
sujets diplomatiques et un sujet aussi
complexe que l'espace de l'ancien empire
soviétique et russe soit simple il y a
un point d'arriver à l'analyse que vous
faites et la lecture de l'histoire
Marine Le Pen a dit la Russie
a eu la Crimée pendant 200 ans l'Ukraine
60 ans donc elle est russe voilà donc
vous demandez si vous étiez sur cette
même ligne oui je suis sur la évidemment
la ligne de Marine Le Pen mais c'est pas
la ligne seulement de Marine Le Pen je
le rappelle que Nicolas Sarkozy
Giscard d'Estaing et j'ai lu monsieur
j'ai entendu Monsieur Obama il y a
quelques jours qui avait une analyse
semblable du sort
j'ai pas regardé on va regarder ça
intéressant Brigitte boucher tam-tam
merci à vous de nous avoir rejoint
évidemment pour toutes les questions
d'actualité on commence par vous Tam et
on va parler du déplacement d'Emmanuel
Macron à Marseille et l'une de ses
premières annonces concernent la drogue
il a annoncé aujourd'hui rendre les
amendes pour consommation de drogue
payable immédiatement carte bleue ou en
liquide cela alors que plus d'un tiers
des amendes forfaitaire pour
consommation de drague de drogue
seulement sont réglés aujourd'hui ça va
dans le bon sens c'est efficace pour
vous moi je faire qu'une peine soit
appliquée plutôt qu'elle ne soit pas
appliquée mais en fait moi je suis
contre la le fait que ce soit une simple
contravention pour moi le fait d'avoir
passé la répression de la consommation
de drogue à un niveau de d'une simple
contravention à banaliser l'usage et la
consommation de la drogue qui a été déjà
très banalisé dans notre pays et je
pense que c'est la faille essentielle de
la lutte contre la drogue retourner en
arrière sur le fait que ce soit un délit
judiciaireisé mais par contre avec une
politique beaucoup plus agressive contre
la consommation de drogue avec des
campagnes de prévention très fortes les
gens ne font jamais de prison derrière
finalement ça revient même mais c'est se
retrouve dans la rue et c'est une faille
générale de la politique contre la
drogue je pense que nous avons enfin les
gouvernements qui se sont succédés ont
été bien faibles face à la consommation
de drogue que la consommation de drogue
dans notre pays le cannabis la cocaïne
mais aussi des drogues malheureusement
plus durs aussi maintenant ça tombe de
médicaments sur la triste voir des
États-Unis devient un sujet de santé
publique très important pas seulement
dans les villes beaucoup de personnes
isolées dans les campagnes aussi
aujourd'hui sont soumises à la tentation
et au risque de la drogue et ça devient
un énorme problème de santé publique les
États-Unis sont la première puissance
occidentale avoir perdu de l'espérance
de vie à cause de la vulgarisation de la
connaissance
le fait de vouloir agir sur les
consommateurs de cette façon là non je
pense que ça ne fonctionnera pas parce
que paradoxalement cette contravention
devient un risque acceptable et en fait
ils vont payer pour consommer de la
drogue et il n'y a on ne diabolise pas
parce qu'il faut le faire la drogue
comme on doit le faire voilà
un des effets majeurs du trafic
aujourd'hui à Marseille c'est là
violence dans les quartiers il y a un
assassinat à Marseille par semaine
depuis le début de l'année qu'est-ce que
vous proposez de faire
il faut une politique beaucoup plus dure
sur la répression des gangs et la
justice mais de la même manière pour la
drogue si vous laissez une la
conséquence finale de 50 ans c'est pas
que le gouvernement de Monsieur les
gouvernements monsieur Macron il n'y a
pas assez de place de prison il n'y a
pas assez de magistrats elle rappelle
que nous avons proposé nous de doubler à
tripler le nombre de magistrats en
France puisque c'est pas la faute
toujours un faux débat disant est-ce que
les Juifs sont laxiste non les délais de
la justice sont-elles le manque de
prison mais le budget de la justice a
été doublée il y a 5 milliards qui ont
été investis pour Marseille c'est pour
ça qu'on a bouché que rien n'a été fait
pendant
la responsabilité de la situation à
Marseille ou de l'état de notre système
judiciaire uniquement monsieur Macron
j'ai justement dit il faut reconnaître
évidemment doubler comment dire
augmenter pardon de manière très
importante les moyens de la justice nous
l'avons nous l'avons soutenu mais par
exemple sur la construction de prison
Emmanuel Macron n'a pas été du tout à la
hauteur mais François Hollande n'avait
pas non plus été à la hauteur en faisant
en promettant de faire en 10 ans ce que
Sarkozy avait pas envie de faire en 5
qui n'avait pas non plus lui fait donc
nous sommes très en retard et
aujourd'hui ça se fait plein pot et
évidemment le la capacité à contrôler
nos frontières à contrôler
l'immigrations et légales aujourd'hui
pour ce qui est de Marseille de Paris ou
des métropoles le l'immigration illégale
clandestine joue un rôle
très effraie déterminant dans la course
dans la dans la structuration du trafic
de drogue à tout niveau et à certains
nombreux aussi d'ailleurs de parrains de
caïd sont maintenant à l'extérieur de
nos frontières et utilise aussi le fait
que les frontières sont des passois pour
gérer leurs traces
la densité du trafic touche tous les
pays européens et là je pense qu'on va
en parler aux campagnes à la campagne
européenne l'année prochaine il s'agit
pas d'opposer est-ce qu'on est tout seul
en France ou complètement fédéralisé
quelle politique on mène au niveau
européen de manière pertinente quel
pouvoir en délègue quel pouvoir en
exerce nous-mêmes pour lutter de manière
efficace contre la drogue est-ce que
vous êtes la mise en place une
commission d'enquête parlementaire sur
la violence à Marseille qui pourrait
même être élargie à d'autres villes
c'est une demande du groupe socialiste
au Sénat de Marie-Arlette Carlotti qui
est élu des Bouches-du-Rhône moi en soi
je ne suis pas aussi c'est toujours
utile de faire des travaux il faut
reconnaître que le Sénat mène
d'excellentes commissions d'enquêtes
parlementaire y compris quand elles
viennent des socialistes depuis quelques
années donc je n'y suis pas hostile
cependant je pense que sur ce qui est de
la violence à Marseille ou dans d'autres
villes puisque maintenant c'est pareil à
Nice ça devient pareil à Toulouse à
Paris dans certains quartiers dans le
nord de la capitale Amiens d'or chez moi
la violence et devient endémique je
pense qu'on sait en fait les causes et
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire et de toute
façon tant qu'il n'y a pas les
magistrats adéquats les forces de police
adéquate mais surtout les prisons parce
qu'il s'agit pas seulement en fait qui
est les bonnes places il faut aussi qui
est suffisamment d'établissement pour
trier les personnes parce que si vous
mélangez des gros caïdes avec des
délinquants des prix modélinquants vous
augmentez les risques au lieu de
favoriser l'insertion et des peines
utiles donc le fait qu'il manque de
prison c'est pas seulement un problème
pour exercer c'est qu'en fait on fait
prendre plus de risques à la société
française sans parler évidemment des
conditions humanitaires
Gérald Darmanin était en Guyane pour
défendre l'opération wambushu à Mayotte
à Mayotte pardon il a déclaré que la
France était en train de reprendre la
main sur la démocratie avec 275 bidons
villes détruits visent le millier depuis
le début de l'année est-ce que vous
saluez l'action de l'État et l'action
des forces de l'ordre sur place oui mais
moi vous savez je ne suis jamais pour la
politique du pire donc quand il y a une
politique même si elle n'est pas aussi
forte que ce qu'on souhaiterait aussi
puissante que ce qu'on souhaiterait ça
va dans le bon sens cependant le
problème de base demeure c'est la
possibilité
d'expulser le nombre de clandestins
considérables qu'il y a à Mayotte
puisque les Comores ne veulent pas
coopérer malgré
tout
s'améliorations Gérald Darmanin compte
tenu de la situation de Mayotte et
compte tenu de l'agenda d'ailleurs qui
n'est pas caché du gouvernement des
Comores qui en fait de récupérer
ou l'autre Mayotte je pense que le
gouvernement est naïf et que les gestes
qui ont pu être faits ne sont pas la
dimension de ce que nous attendons
je suis jamais dans la politique du
piano quand il y a quelque chose de bien
je le prends mais je ne suis pas naïf là
les caméras sont braquées sur Mayotte ce
que nous voyons de la volonté des
Comores et de la faiblesse quand même de
longue durée du gouvernement je ne suis
pas naïf je pense qu'il faut être très
vigilant et je pense qu'aujourd'hui nous
n'obtenons pas des Comores ce qu'une
puissance comme la France est en droit
de demander il s'agit quand même de la
sixième puissance mondiale qui fait face
à l'archipel des Comores qui n'est par
exemple qui devrait quand même pas vous
feriez quoi vous vous feriez quoi si
vous étiez au responsabilités totalement
toutes les aides au développement coupez
toutes les arrivées de financement de la
diaspora comorienne en France
si vous coupez les aides au
développement vous vous aggravez encore
la situation sur place et vous
encouragez encore plus les gens à partir
de tes Comores cédrat bien avant que ça
devient
pour pour qu'on puisse les Comores ouais
c'est un état qui n'a pas une grande
force de négociation autre qu'en fait le
comment dire le désarmement moral de
l'État français face à un certain nombre
de puissance étrangères mais c'est il y
avait que les Comores bon l'État
français depuis des années ne considère
pas moralement dans ces structures
profondes qu'il faille imposer sa
volonté à d'autres États voilà nous
avons nous avons
sur la table qui a été discuté en partie
au Sénat qui reviendra à l'automne il
prévoit deux volets donc un volet sur la
régularisation des métiers en tension et
puis une politique plus ferme envers les
îles Lego est-ce que vous pourriez voter
ce projet de loi vous qui défendez
depuis toujours des restrictions plus
fortes sur l'immigration
j'en doute nous pourrons voter des
mesures ponctuelles évidemment si le
gouvernement décide de ramener à trois
seulement les possibilités de recours
pour les clandestins qui veulent
contester leur expulsion nous sout tout
ce qui va dans ce sens là mais plus le
mois passe plus on se rend compte que
cette loi est en fait très faible sur la
répression de l'immigration illégale sur
la reprise de contrôle des frontières et
qu'il s'agit en fait essentiellement de
créer une nouvelle filière de
régularisation par le travail de ce qui
sont déjà présents sur le territoire qui
deviendra évidemment une nouvelle
filière avec des gens qui viendront de
plus en plus
cette mesure
aujourd'hui il y a plein de restaurants
et notamment le bourbon que vous
connaissez bien
vous avez vu il tourne alors pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui
c'est le café qui joue que c'est le café
politique
c'est ce que dit le patron du bourbon
s'il y avait pas pousser par exemple
dans le monde c'était intéressant cet
article au-delà des cas individuels où
il y a des gens dans le courage de qui
ces personnes immigrées quand d’estime
qui viennent s'en courageuse se lève tôt
pour travailler sont alertes au travail
c'est ça je ne dis pas le contraire mais
quand vous voyez les salaires dont parle
cet article on parle de 1500 à 2000
euros par mois dans l'article du Monde
pour se lever à 5h du matin pour venir
faire l'ouverture faire des travaux très
pénibles dans une cuisine où il fait
très chaud et ça rentre chez soi par le
dernier RER si on peut la voir
à 23 heures minuit donc en fait la
réalité de cet article c'est que les
salaires sont encore très bas dans la
restauration bon on parle du sang
il partait très bas madame j'ai
travaillé 5 ans dans la restauration
j'ai été payé au lance-pierre avec des
conditions de travail très dures avec
une pause
avec des études non plus donc en fait
sur l'échelle des valeurs en fait il
faut aussi qu'il y ait une graduation
non mais ça c'est une vision française
que je conteste si le marché du travail
est difficile c'est que les salaires ne
sont pas assez élevés il faut les
augmenter il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui
vont travailler en Suisse au Luxembourg
en Belgique à Londres parce que les
salaires dans la restauration sont
meilleurs mais c'est que les Français
accepteraient de prendre ses postes là
s'ils étaient mieux payés
ce sont des Français de
souche ou de d'immigrés plusieurs
générations qui travaillent moi je il y
a parfois une dichotomie parisienne
croyant que les Français dans les
territoires ne veulent plus travailler
non c'est très différent c'est
spécifique à Paris parce que on est à la
concurrence de personnes qui viennent
qui ont besoin de travailler à des prix
à des salaires assez bas et je suis
désolé on a compris que votre mais dans
le 7e arrondissement c'est pas un petit
restaurant qui a pas d'argent oui c'est
ça aussi ce qui était curieux dans le
monde c'est que je pense qu'ils ont les
moyens de payer mieux leur leurs
employés alors on va continuer à parler
de ce projet de loi immigration il y a
un alignement du gouvernement sur la
position du Sénat puisqu'ils vont
reprendre le texte de la Commission à
l'automne vous y voyez un début
d'alliance entre LR et le gouvernement
c'est plus qu'un début d'alliance Sénat
ça commence à faire un bout de temps
qu'il y a une belle alliance enfin si je
puis dire entre les républicains et le
gouvernement on l'a déjà vu sur la
trahison Intex par exemple ou le
républicains aurait dû voter contre le
texte sur les énergies renouvelables en
particulier la plantation des éoliennes
les républicains c'était engagés auprès
des maires un ruraux qui d'ailleurs sans
doute l'essence
au produit très faiblement on avait
parlé d'un droit de veto des mers d'une
consultation obligatoire de protéger par
exemple un département comme le mis à la
somme qui est objectivement tout le
monde le reconnaît y compris le
gouvernement saturé d'éoliennes et bien
finalement le Sénat c'est couché pour
une raison simple les républicains comme
partie comme intérêt de partie on son
terrifiés par la dissolution
c'est pas tout à fait alors on continue
une motion de censure éventuellement sur
la loi immigration
de gouvernement de savoir si oui ou non
ils vont au bout de républicain pardon
de savoir si oui ou non ils vont au bout
de leur prétent quoi ce qui peut y avoir
une majorité c'est ce que vous vouliez
demander une majorité du coup à
l'Assemblée la ligne rouge c'est censé
être la régularisation pour les
républicainston Park pour Madame borne
d'autre part l'un n'en veut pas l'autre
le veut absolument des clandestins qui
travaille donc si les républicains sont
cohérents le texte ne peut pas passer si
Madame borne est cohérente elle ne
soutera pas son propre texte donc je
vois pas si le changement
une question parce que le texte il a été
considérablement durci par le Sénat sur
la question des quotas sur l'aide
médicale d'État qui est transformée en
aide médicale d'urgence sur les
récemment des critères pour le
regroupement familial tout ça là-dessus
vous seriez d'accord vous pourriez voter
toutes ces mesures vous pourriez voter
ce texte absolument mais l'Assemblée
nationale je pense en tout cas la
majorité enfin la minorité
présidentielle va rétablir un autre
texte là sans doute pour ce qui est de
l'aide médicale d'État pour interdire
les quotas bon bref toutes les mesures
de restriction le la minorité
présidentielle la macronie va sans doute
rétablir le texte précédent avec l'aide
sans doute des socialistes et des vers
et tenter de faire passer d'autres
choses avec les républicains et au final
donc il y aura pas d'alliance entre le
gouvernement
et à l'instant c'est ce que ça m'inspire
quand j'entends effectivement j'ai lu
effectivement les trouvailles du Sénat
mais ne soyez enfin ne soyons pas dupe
sur le fait que les Sénat fait des
effets d'annonce sachant très bien que
ce sera pas suivi par l'Assemblée ils
veulent refiler le mistigri de la
responsabilité de ce bazar et de cette
incohérence au gouvernement après avoir
assumé leur a popularité sur les
retraites puisqu'on sait que l'essentiel
de l'inspiration du texte sur le
justicement des retraites venez lui-même
du cinéma donc le Sénat essaie de faire
parce qu'il vous rappelle que des
élections sanatoriales dans quelques
semaines essayer de faire vous avez
toute une théorie mais parce que je
connais mes grands électeurs et je
connais les républicains que j'ai quand
même trop fréquentés par le passé voilà
donc ils essaient de faire oublier ça en
se faisant passer pour des gros bras je
pense que les électeurs et les grands
électeurs ne sont pas dupes et qu'à la
fin on se rendra compte que les
républicains sont en fait paralysées
tétanisé par toute perspective de mise
en minorité frontale du gouvernement
donc d'une motion censure et donc d'une
possible dissolution de son surface
alors moi j'ai une question la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale il y
a LeBron Pivet qui ne souhaite pas
changer la composition du bureau de
l'Assemblée et donc conserver tel qu'il
est c'est à dire avec les
vice-présidents RN il avait été question
et notamment Aurore berger avait laissé
entendre qui pourrait y avoir des
changements est-ce que vous êtes rassuré
par ces propos qu'on a pu lire dans Le
Parisien rassuré non parce que Madame
von Pivet c'est sans doute à son honneur
mais enfin ne fait qu'appliquer non
seulement l'esprit de la Constitution
évidemment mais notre règlement voilà le
règlement prévoit que le bureau
parce qu'en fait on débat quelque chose
dont on ne devrait pas débattre il n'y a
aucun débat sur le fait que le RN et de
vice-président ou que nous soyons
représentés
dans la majorité présidentielle
ce sont des gens qui ne respectent pas
en fait la démocratie on l'a vu avec la
remise en cause aussi l'autorité du
président Coquerel la commission des
finances je l'ai présenté contre lui
donc c'est pas un ami mais il a exercé
son droit constitutionnel à considérer
que la loi la remise en cause pardon de
la de la retraite de du gros pilote ne
remettez pas en cause l'article 40 et la
soutenabilité financière c'est aussi
libre droit c'est pas à la macronie de
décerner les bons les mauvais points de
ce qu'est la bonne opposition de ce qui
ne l'est pas donc d'une manière générale
non mais la Constitution et il y a le
respect de la Constitution donc si
l'interprétation de ce Coquerel si les
Français ne sont pas d'accord avec
l'interprétation de la constitution de
Monsieur coffret par exemple ce seront
eux qui est de votre plus beau
mon petit doigt j'ai pas essayé de jouer
au plus malin pour essayer de remplacer
monsieur Coquerel sur un malentendu j'ai
dit qu'il avait eu raison de suivre
cette interprétation
en octobre par exemple je pense que je
serai candidat par principe mais par
contre je ne participerai aucune
magouille qui consiste par exemple à
donner la présidence de la photo à
Madame lovaji non pas qu'une respecte
pas Madame lovaquie des républicains
mais parce que ce n'est pas une
opposante frontale de toute évidence à
la député LR votre collègue merci
beaucoup Brigitte Etam et on rejoint
tout de suite avant d'accueillir Yves
Thréard Vincent roux bonjour Vincent
est-ce que vous êtes là avec nous oui
vous m'entendez Vincent
à vous
bonsoir Elisabeth bonsoir Jean-Philippe
Tanguy Barack Obama a exprimé en fin de
semaine dernière un regret il a regretté
qu'on avait porté plus d'attention
peut-être même autant si non plus au
sort du sous-marin le Titan et au 5
membres d'équipage qui ont tragiquement
disparu dans l’implosion du sous-marin
qu'au naufrage des 700 migrants au large
de la Grèce dans la nuit du 13 au 14
juin dernier est-ce que vous partagez le
regret de l'ancien président américain
oui enfin je pense qu'il a raison il y a
pas une concurrence des tragédies mais
il est vrai que la multiplication des
tragédies des disparitions en mer
Méditerranée de bateau de migrants par
qui sont transportés par des criminels
par des passeurs par des gens qui
abusent de leurs espoirs et de leurs
misères il y a une certaine
vulgarisation malheureusement ce terme
est horrible et les il faut que ça passe
et que on ne fait plus attention aux
causes or nous on ne veut pas comment
dire il s'agit pas de punir les
personnes qui tentent de traverser la
mer on veut les empêcher de traverser la
mer et c'est pour ça qu'on devait être
politique très ferme à l'australienne
leur faisant comprendre qu'il n'y a
aucun avenir pour eux sur le continent
européen et que donc il ne sert à rien
de prendre la mer et nous pensons que
c'est la seule politique d'humanité
complétée évidemment par une grande
politique de développement en Afrique
notamment les transferts technologiques
qui tarde merci beaucoup Vincent on vous
retrouve tout à l'heure pour une autre
question d'actualité on connaît votre on
connaît votre point de vue sur la
question merci beaucoup Vincent à tout à
l'heure bien sûr à la fin d'audition
publique
c'était trop médiatisé ok à tout à
l'heure et ben voilà ça a été bah oui
c'était bien votre réponse vous avez
trouvé que en tout cas il y avait une
disproportion oui bien sûr
dans une espèce de d'opposition de
morale qui est inefficace et qui au
final est meurtrières Yves très har
directeur adjoint la rédaction du Figaro
bonsoir à vous bonsoir Elisabeth bonsoir
Jean-Philippe Tanguy il y a un sondage
comme tous les dimanches d'ailleurs qui
est tombé de l'Ifop sur
le sentiment que les Français ont le
regard que les français portent sur le
rassemblement national et pour 21 % des
Français interrogés ce qui est quand
même parisien c'est près du cas et bien
le rassemblement national serait un
danger pour la démocratie qu'est-ce que
vous leur répondez
je leur réponds qu'il ne doivent pas
écouter ce qu'il reste de propagande
contre nous mais bon je me permets aussi
c'est eux qui parle c'est pas la
propriété il pense qu'il devrait plus
écouter ce qu'on dit moi ce qu'on dit de
nous voilà mais après par rapport à
l'évolution vous savez la politique et
vous aurez un observateur avisé c'est le
long court je pense que c'est une
évolution
de fond qui a réussi Marine Le Pen et
aujourd'hui le fait qu'il n'y ait plus
que ce nombre-là de gens qui nous
craignent est très important voilà vous
savez si on le faisait pour d'autres
parties je suis pas sûr que le
rassemblement national serait le parti
plus craint de France il y a d'autres
sondages
la France insoumise a aussi un très
mauvais chiffre je pense que si on
testait d'autres on aurait des surprises
parce que d'ailleurs c'est dans le
Figaro qui chaque mois fait un sondage
cantar le le rassemble national est
aujourd'hui une partie le plus populaire
aussi en France donc bon vous savez les
chiffres aussi sont des petits créatures
fragiles comme des autres personnes
est-ce que néanmoins vous estimez que la
la tactique de la cravate comme on
l'appelle c'est-à-dire que vous êtes
tous très bien mis vous le premier
d'ailleurs à l'Assemblée nationale
est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui vous
sert par rapport
au style plutôt davantage débraillé de
la France insoumise débraillés moi c'est
surtout que n'explique pas en fait la
stratégie de la France insoumise et de
leurs amis notamment des verbes enfin ça
c'est leur problème c'est pas le c'est
pas le sourire pour revoir le règlement
de la je pense que le fait d'avoir
compris vestimentaire oui parce qu'on a
rajouté une veste mais ça empêche pas
certains de insoumis de mettre un sweat
à capuche ou un t-shirt dégueulasse
mettre une veste dessus ça n'enlève pas
ça cache pas la misère si je puis dire
voilà bon d'ailleurs c'est surtout quand
même les hommes qui se comportent comme
ça je sais pas c'est quand même très
étrange le et puis ça s'accompagne
explique il y aurait que le
vestimentaire parce que tout ça est
superficiel mais c'est aussi une
attitude c'est une vulgarité c'est un
manque de respect des institutions
notamment de la présidente one PV met
d'autres une façon aussi très
vindicative personnelle d'attaquer les
gens sur leur personne pas sur leurs
idées sur leur personne sur leur
engagement sur leur sincérité sur leur
se disant compromission corruption c'est
arrivé plusieurs fois avec des choses
qui ne sont pas prouvées et ils abusent
vous savez on peut dire n'importe quoi
en séance on est protégé par la
Constitution qu'on est parlementaire
donc vous pouvez diffamer insulter
raconter n'importe quoi sur vos
collègues parlementaires vous ne pouvez
pas être poursuivi par exemple en
diffamation
avait accusé madame Braun Pivet d'avoir
des actions et d'être en conflit
d'intérêt carrément corrompu par rapport
à ces participations en bourse n'avait
aucun sens ça n'était prouvé sur rien je
pense qu'il n'aurait pas dit la même
chose en dehors de l'hémicycle et pas
protégé par la Constitution donc c'est
un comportement qui est quand même
odieux au sens strict du terme alors
parce que vous n'avez pas aussi un petit
problème de ligne en fait parce que on
vous reproche de pas dire grand chose et
c'est vrai que vous ne dites pas grand
chose à l'Assemblée nationale pas vous
mais votre votre groupe est-ce que on
n'a pas de ligne au rassemblement
national aujourd'hui qui se font un peu
face avec Monsieur Bardella qui défend
une ligne d'avantage d'identitaire sur
les problèmes régaliens et en face
Madame Le Pen qui elle est davantage sur
une ligne sociale est-ce qu'il y a pas
là et bien deux discours qui sommes
toutes sont un peu différents non
sincèrement je ne crois pas monsieur
barthela pendant la présidentielle a
défendu le programme de sur le pouvoir
d'achat très important de défense des
acquis sociaux pendant les retraites
aussi c'est Monsieur Bardella qui a fait
les anciennes des débats notamment
contre Monsieur Attal ou monsieur du
stop sur les retraites en défendant
évidemment naturellement notre programme
sur les retraites donc je pense que
cette construction
médiatique mais c'est pas une critique
c'est c'est le commentaire c'est comme
ça c'est la démocratie et mon avis est
exagéré et et ne correspond pas
correspond pas à grand chose il se
trouve aussi que l'Assemblée nationale a
beaucoup débattu d'abord du pouvoir
d'achat ensuite de la question des
retraites moins de l'immigration qui
aujourd'hui à l'ordre du jour donc la
ligne de défense des frontières de
l'identité française va forcément
s'affirmer quand le texte va être
présenté au Parlement alors il y a une
deuxième occasion aussi c'est l'occasion
des élections européennes qui vont avoir
lieu dans un an là vous allez être mis
en concurrence probablement avec
reconquête le parti de monsieur Éric
Zemmour peut-être avec lui-même
d'ailleurs aussi est-ce que là il y a
pas un risque justement que vous fassiez
volé une partie de votre fond de
commerce non je crois pas
que ce soit à fond de commerce parce que
ce sont des idées qui méritent d'être
défendues à programme et cela vision
qu'on a de l'immigration de l'identité
française du contrôle des frontières
nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec
Eric Zemmour donc les Français vous le
trouvez trop radical c'est une vision
différente j'ai pas la juger mais il est
essentialise beaucoup les personnes ils
pensent à certains noms
il pense que l'assimilation le modèle
assimilialise vous savez il y a d'autres
pays d'autres civilisations qui ne
pensent pas comme la France qu'il y a
une culture universelle que toute
personne peut être assimilée vous êtes
pour l'intégration alors nous on est
pour l'assimilation puisque
l'intégration oui bien sûr on pense que
la République française la nation
française la civilisation française doit
assimiler ses enfants d'où qu'ils
viennent il y a un courant d'ailleurs
moins monsieur Zemmour lui-même que des
gens fait reconquête qui pensent que
l'assimilation n'est pas possible pour
tout le monde que ce qu'on appelle les
Identitaires bon ils ont le droit de le
penser moi je ne pense pas que ce soit
raciste
on n'est pas pour on est pour presque
zéro immigration mais par exemple il y a
des étudiants qui peuvent rester en
France s'ils sont nécessaires par
exemple un certain nombre de soignants
même s'il faut pas non plus piller les
pays en voie de développement de leur
force vive donc on va pour zéro
immigration mais on est pour un contrôle
strict de l'immigration je pense pas
mais beaucoup d'eau dans votre vin hein
l'objectif est évidemment de ne plus
avoir de clandestins du tout c'est de
contrôler parfaitement qui peut rentrer
dans notre territoire par exemple de il
y a zéro immigration familiale c'est
nous hein bon il y a zéro migration sur
des métiers qui sont pas comment dire
qualifiés voilà bon non qualifié parce
que l'intention je pense que c'était le
débat qu'on a vu quand vous avez 5
millions de chômeurs vous pouvez former
les gens en France qui sont sur les
métiers en tension par contre si vous
avez besoin d'un physicien nucléaire
pour les centrales nucléaires par
exemple c'est ma spécialité on a eu
besoin de soudeur extrêmement qualifié
vous ne pouvez pas les former en un
claquement de doigts donc oui la voûte
fait faire rentrer par exemple des
soudeurs de chaudière nucléaire voilà
donc c'est une fermeture des frontières
avec quand même des ouvertures c'est
peut-être la leçon du brexit puisqu'on a
vu que la Grande-Bretagne a récupéré ses
frontières il y a jamais eu autant de
migrants des 30 dernières années je
pense que vous savez vous avez une des
institutions vous avez un gouvernement
qui veut le brexit pour que les
Britanniques décident ce qu'ils veulent
voilà
autrement aujourd'hui j'ai vécu au Japon
au Japon vous avez un contrôle très
strict des frontières ne rendent que les
personnes qui doivent
je vais lancer carrément un pays qui
n'accepte pas à l'étranger
c'est le Japon et le japonais défendent
leurs intelligents la Corée
il y a une petite musique qui monte
actuellement qui dit Madame Le Pen
risque de perdre à terme son meilleur
adversaire politique qui s'appelle
Emmanuel Macron
voilà il avait lu le point l'article de
Charles sapin
est-ce que c'est vrai que c'est votre
meilleur adversaire finalement Emmanuel
Macron parce que c'est vraiment le ying
et le yang là c'est c'est deux
oppositions très nettes et très claires
tout à fait c'est vrai mais visiblement
ce qui remplaceront un el Macron sont
sans doute aussi très opposés à nous
très responsable de la situation
dégradation de la France iront peut-être
pas certains talents que peut avoir
monsieur Macron parce que c'est il faut
reconnaître les talents de l'adversaire
à Monsieur Macron était malheureusement
pour notre pays un adversaire redoutable
roublard qui manque comme il respire qui
arrive à faire passer des vessies des
des vessies pour des lanternes bon donc
il est malheureusement redoutable je
pense que ceux qui vont le succéder le
son moins tout à l'heure ils arrêtent
faisait référence à Poutine à Vladimir
Poutine et à ce qui s'est passé ce
week-end en Russie vous avez
créé une commission d'enquête
parlementaire pour savoir quelles
étaient les liens effectivement les
relations entre votre partie d'ingérence
sur le s'il y avait des ingérences et la
Russie
la Russie de Poutine cette commission a
été très critiquée finalement avec une
conclusion par leur rapporteur qui était
une rapporteuse qui a été très sévère
pour pour vous est-ce que vous vous
mordez les doigts un peu de cette
d'avoir créé cette commission qui
finalement a servi à rien du tout
mais pas du tout alors c'est vrai que on
a été pris dans une petite tempête
médiatique où les paroles de l'âme le
grip était pris comme parole d'évangile
je pense que tout se dire ça s'est
arrêté quand le rapport a été publié
parce que je pense que les journalistes
qui ont lu le vraiment le rapport se
sont se rend compte que ce que disait
madame le grip n'était fondé en rien
qu'il n'y avait donc pas grand chose à
dire la motivation vous savez on m'a
fait passer parfois pour que je ne pense
pas être et le but de ce rapport n'était
pas d'avoir un rapport sympathique de
nos adversaires politiques c'était que
les Français en toute transparence
voient que les services de renseignement
la Commission nationale des comptes de
campagne toutes les institutions qui
protègent la République et notre
démocratie témoigne que le rassemblement
national n'avait rien à voir avec une
quelconque ingérence c'est ce qu'on dit
sous serment tous les services de
renseignement que nous avons auditionnés
maintenant tout le monde peut les
consulter et nous avons des pièces pour
répondre à nos adversaires merci est-ce
que vous serez candidats aux élections
européennes alors pas du tout moi je
serais pas
candidat rien là pour l'instant à part
voilà c'est ce qu'on a compris une
dissolution merci évidemment vous
l'espérez merci beaucoup ultra on va
accueillir bien sûr le député MoDem
Bruno milliennes et en attendant une
question sur le Journal du Dimanche qui
est en grève vous le savez qui a été en
grève qui n'est pas paru dans les
kiosques hier
la rédaction c'est cabrée lorsqu'elle a
été annoncé l'arrivée de Geoffroy
Lejeune qui vient de l'heure actuelle
d'abord est-ce que vous comprenez cette
réaction de la rédaction moi je
comprends toute liberté des journalistes
à s'exprimer donc moi je pense pas que
les hommes politiques et qu'ils soient
ou les responsables gouvernementaux
doivent s'immiscer dans les affaires
d'un journal il faut que le droit soit
respecté donc est-ce que les droits pour
vous cette grève est légitime c'est le
droit de la nomination de Monsieur le
jeune me paraît légitime la grève est
légitime et ça va être une relation
entre les journalistes leur actionnaires
et la nouvelle équipe et ils vont
s'entendre je le vois pas en quoi les
hommes politiques doivent se mêler de la
ligne éditoriale des journals des
journaux sur l'indépendance de la presse
par exemple illustré par la prise de
pouvoir de Monsieur Bolloré sur le
Journal du Dimanche monsieur Bolloré
plus que d'autres moi j'ai je suis pas
du tout hostile et depuis très longtemps
et d'ailleurs je crois aussi que c'était
une réflexion de Monsieur Berrou il y a
quelques années de réfléchir à la
structure capitalistique des médias en
France est-ce qu'il y a des
concentrations excessives sans doute
est-ce qu'il faut interdire à des
entreprises qui ont des intérêts publics
ou qui sont liés à des commandes
publiques de posséder des médias ou qui
sont liés à la diplomatie française je
pense que le par contre le débat doit se
tenir et ce serait bien que ce débat se
tienne parce que l'indépendance des
journalistes est une valeur sacrée de la
démocratie et en France la structure
capitaliste des médias pas selon
Monsieur Bolloré la concentration mais
juste une dernière question certains
politiques comme la ministre de la
culture ou la patronne de la CGT on dit
leur émotion leur inquiétude par rapport
à la défense des valeurs républicaines
contenu de la prise de contrôle de du
groupe Bolloré pardon du GDD par le
groupe Bolloré est-ce que vous partagez
cette inquiétude je ne vois pas en quoi
ils n'ont pas porté de preuves après les
ministres à la qu'a apporté des preuves
mais quand monsieur Gattegno qui était
ancien rédacteur en chef du JDD disait
ouvertement qu'il refusait d'interviewer
Madame Le Pen on n'a pas entendu à
l'époque
des responsables gouvernementaux dire
que c'était pas normal donc moi vous
savez j'ai des principes les applique à
mes amis à mes ennemis donc je veux que
ce débat je vais j'estime le débat sur
le capital des médias peut se tenir en
France c'est intéressant une seule un
seul catégorie de média Monsieur Bruno
milleniène merci de nous avoir rejoint
dans ce studio vous êtes député MoDem
vous allez tout à l'heure aborder la
question de la trajectoire budgétaire
qui vous tient à cœur mais d'abord les
szf sont trois lettres dites nous de
quoi il s'agit vous les défendez oui
alors Monsieur Tanguy moi j'ai été j'ai
été un peu surpris venant de voix du
groupe que en janvier dernier dans votre
niche parlementaire vous proposiez un
texte qui proposait rien de moins que de
supprimer les zones à faibles émission
mobilité qui sont ces zones qui vont
réglementer la circulation dans le
périmètre de certaines métropoles à 43
aujourd'hui un peu moins parce qu'il y
en a qui sortent déjà et c'est un c'est
une mesure de de santé publique en fait
pour limiter la pollution la pollution
de l'air j'en avais longuement parlé
avec le porteur du texte pierre Meurin à
qui je reproche un petit peu si vous me
le permettez
d'avoir pas suivi les travaux qu'on a
mené depuis on a commis un rapport avec
Gérard le seul une mission flash sur ce
sujet là qui a bien mis en exergue
effectivement les difficultés et j'ai eu
l'impression j'ai eu l'impression que
cette PPL que vous aviez proposé était
plus quelque chose de l'ordre d'agiter
la peur plutôt que de voir réellement
les travaux qui ont été engagés parce
que je vous rappelle quand même que
juste après la promulgation de ce
rapport une semaine après donc ça va
durer très longtemps le ministère de la
transition écologique s'est engagé
Christophe bechuit s'est engagé à mettre
en place effectivement des groupes de
travail pour qu'on arrive à résoudre les
points épineux moi je vous accorde que
c'était un petit peu nébuleux avant
qu'on fasse le rapport depuis ça s'est
considérablement amélioré et il y a
plein de solutions qui remontent du
terrain pour faire en sorte qu'on puisse
lutter contre cette pollution de l'air
qui je le rappelle quand même provoque
48 000 morts par an d'accord et c'est
deux ans un peu plus de deux ans
d'espérance de vie en moins pour les
Français 4 ans et demi par exemple à
Paris donc pas question à la suivante
regarde des travaux menés si toutefois
vous les avez suivi souhaitez-vous
toujours supprimer les aidefe et le cas
échéant quels sont vos solutions
concrètes pour lutter contre la
pollution de l'air dans nos métropoles
oui on veut toujours les supprimer
monsieur Mylène parce qu'en fait nous
n'avons pas la même philosophie
politique sur ce qui est de la quant à
la responsabilité de la pollution dans
nos villes pendant des années vous le
savez les gouvernements français
successifs ont subventionné le diesel
ils ont encouragé avec des dizaines de
milliards d'euros deectaxations les
Français à s'équiper en diesel et alors
qu'ils auraient pu mener depuis la
première crise pétrolière dans les
années 70 une politique déjà de
développement des véhicules électriques
des mobilités alternatives fondées sur
notre génie nucléaire vous ils ne l'ont
pas fait et du jour au lendemain on fait
porter au plus modeste d'entre nous au
classement moyennes aussi
parce que laissez-moi finir je vous
écoute bah oui bah si vous avez déjà la
réponse avant la mienne la
responsabilité de lutter contre la
solution et vous allez progressivement
ou déjà exclure un certain nombre de
véhicules des territoires vous avez
d'irréguliers il s'agit d'exclusion de
d'un certain nombre de véhicules de gens
qui n'ont pas les moyens de faire
autrement amplifiant une fracture
territoriale et sociale déjà très forte
dans notre dans notre pays donc
peut-être que vous ayez pas peut-être
effectivement les travaux mènent à une
nuance qui prouve déjà que notre alerte
n'a pas été inutile puisque c'était
madame frigo c'était un frigo avant
monsieur Merin la député que nous avons
malheureusement perdu suite à
l'annulation de son siège qui avait
lancé ce combat puisque à Reims elle
était concernée en premier en premier
ressort et les nuances qui sont qui sont
soulevées ne changent pas cette ce
transfert de responsabilité et le
problème c'est que si vous n'offrez pas
les solutions technologiques aux
personnes les plus modestes pour changer
durablement de véhicule sans que ça
atteinte à leur mode de vie ou à leur
pouvoir d'achat vous transférez la
responsabilité du gouvernement vers les
citoyens et nous nous sommes pour nous
nous sommes dans la logique inverse nous
pensons que c'est aux élites françaises
de proposer les solutions et les
infrastructures qui suivent parce que
vous pouvez avoir des véhicules
électriques il y a pas les bornes s'il y
a pas l'électricité pour les recharger
ça ne fonctionne pas et où les
carburants propres d'ailleurs et donc en
fait après n'avoir rien fait de 1973
quand même monsieur Mylène à 2015 et
depuis 2015 va-t-on tout le monde se
réveille en disant faut tout interdire
du jour au lendemain alors il y a une
irresponsabilité générale transfert de
responsabilités
vous faites le constat de ce qui n'a pas
été fait je l'ai fait aussi j'avais pas
besoin de vous c'est pour ça que je me
suis investi sur ce sujet là mais vous
n'avez pas de solution à proposer à part
supprimer bah j'ai pas entendu donc je
vais vous informer simplement qu'il y a
un rapport qui va être remis début
juillet par les groupes de travail qu'on
travaillait avec le ministère la
transition écologique qui sont des
groupes de travail
transpartisans et qui sont des groupes
de travail avec les collectivités
territoriales concernées donc on attend
des résultats importants notamment sur
l'harmonisation des interdictions sur
les solutions effectivement qu'on peut
amener aux gens et pour travailler
dessus personnellement depuis plus d'un
an et demi je peux vous assurer que des
solutions sur le terrain il en arrive il
est pas question d'interdire à quiconque
de pouvoir rentrer d'une scène dans une
ZFE donc pas interdire aux gens d'aller
travailler c'est complètement aberrant
c'est là où je dis que vous attisez les
peurs sans avoir été regardé les
solutions on travaille à déployer toute
une série de solutions qui vont
permettre à chacun de trouver une
alternative pas de le faire en fonction
de son calendrier le calendrier
était dans la vous savez dans la
première loi qui était la loi l'homme
principe de réalité qui prévaut vous
l'avez vu à Paris c'est pas moi qui
l'invente à Paris on aurait dû on aurait
dû déjà arrêter les critères 3 il y a
pas de quoi les remplacer on recule le
truc j'entends beaucoup parler de 2025
2025 c'est la mise en place c'est pas la
ligne d'arrivée la ligne d'arrivée c'est
203200 2000 dans 32 qu'on sera jugé
effectivement sur la baisse de la
pollution de l'air d'ici là si vous
saviez le nombre de solutions qui
émanent du terrain et qu'on envoie
directement au gouvernement pour leur
mise en place pour justement arriver à
faire les choses et quelque chose donc
ça passe par l'interdiction de l'usage
de certains véhicules
si vous prenez la ZF juste
et c'est moi terminé nous avons une
obligation de moyens et pas de résultats
il faut que les Français et ça en tête
l'obligation c'est une obligation moyen
pas de résultats si vous faites de la
ZFE une politique de politique
politicienne c'est voué à l'échec si
vous embarquez pas les gens avec vous
c'est mort donc nous effectivement vous
avez raison c'est notre boulot de
trouver des solutions à mi-juillet au
maximum vous verrez tout un chapelle de
solutions arrivés et moi j'aurais aimé
qu'on est plutôt des solutions qu'on a
pas vu ou qu'on n'a pas imaginé que vous
nous ameniez ça plutôt qu'une
interdiction pure et simple qui va en
rien résoudre le problème de pollution
d'air qui est une un problème de santé
publique nous accusez de ne pas porter
solution à un problème que déjà vous
avez créé vous-même donc nous à partir
du moment on supprime le problème
effectivement on va pas la pollution de
la solution ici parce que la pollution
vous avez pas de chance parce qu'il se
trouve quand j'étais à debout la France
en 2014 et j'ai proposé un plan de
sortie du pétrole qui était structuré
dans le temps mais il était structuré
sur 20 ans il était pas structuré sur
cinq voilà donc ça c'est la différence
d'approche et à l'époque tout le monde
ricané parce qu'à l'époque le non pas
vous-même mais les forces politiques
aujourd'hui vous incarnez considérez que
l'électrification de démobilités c'est
ridicule et ça n'arriverait jamais de la
même manière qu'on nous avait dit que le
nucléaire était mort et enterré alors ça
c'était hier d'accord mais c'est
important parce que le problème de la
macronie c'est qu'il récrive tout sur
les choses ils font des objectifs ils
font culpabiliser les gens et bien quand
ça marche aucune culpabilité monsieur
Tanguy c'est pas vrai c'est pour ça que
ça a pris Arras d'ailleurs vous savez
très bien c'est que c'est très mal passé
à Reims madame frigo a gagné 13 points
entre l'élection Marine Le Pen et ça
quasi réélection sur ce sujet là c'est
que les gens ont pas fantasmer voilà et
donc et donc en fait vous mettez les
gens devant des problèmes et une fois
que vous rendez compte que vous êtes
trompé au lieu de dire on s'est trompé
vous accusez les oppositions qui ont
dénoncé le problème d'avoir voulu
attiser les problèmes de la dénonciation
monsieur quand il y a encore travaillé
les peurs ben oui vous êtes
vous n'avez vous n'avez pas de solution
je suis désolé ça marche je vais vous
dire pourquoi ça marche sur les 43
agglomérations qui doivent en théorie
faire une zfo il y a un déjà neuf qui le
feront pas parce qu'elles sont en
dessous donc vous supprimez le problème
mais non elles sont en dessous des
normes prescrites par l'OMS encore une
fois résultat c'est c'est les moyens non
c'est qu'en fait une obligation de
résultats et pas de moyens en fait la
France en général a et s'il faut il faut
s'en féliciter une pollution
atmosphérique
alors la question c'est effectivement ce
qui nous manque c'est de savoir comment
vous y arrivez si vous êtes d'accord
avec nous on avait on ne pense pas que
ce soit aux Français de trouver les
solutions
pour la planification mais si on a
toujours été pour la planification et
aucune solution mais si la planification
est-ce que Monsieur Macron a repris
aussi l'idée de planification sur la
réductions
je vous ai beaucoup écouté la seule
solution que vous avez présenté pour le
moment la seule solution que vous avez
présenté pour le moment c'est décaler
vos propres normes et décalez vos
produits
on a le droit peut-être au Parlement ne
pas être de complètement nocifié
effectivement c'est pas écrit à votre
place par rapport que vous avez fait et
vous avez pas écrit ma place sur le plan
Marie Curie qui prévoyait de déclarer
l'industrie et si vous ne pose une colle
sur le sur mon propre plan vous allez
pas l'avoir donc moi je ne vous méprise
pas ne méprisez
qu'on a des solutions notamment pour les
plus précaires avec un leasing à 80
euros par mois et ça marchera pas ça on
verra on prend le Paris donc vous êtes
d'accord pour faire l'expérience là
pour la politique du pire mais je pense
que le leasing concernera très peu de
gens ne serait-ce que vous n'avez pas
monsieur il aime les capacités de
production de véhicules électriques ou
hybrides en France suffisant est-ce que
je vais parler d'électrique ou des
brides il y a pas que l'électric ou
hybride dans les solutions de Monsieur
Macron
tout ça il y a tout ce qui permet
effectivement de faire baisser la
pollution de l'air bien on en reparlera
on va arriver à la planification parce
que vous n'avez pas les moyens de
production deuxième sujet Bruno Miliane
le budget alors le budget ça c'est un
domaine que vous connaissez
quand même des choses monsieur Tanguy
vous en parler assez souvent et vous
citez assez souvent le programme de
Marine Le Pen lors de la dernière
présidentielle si je regarde rapidement
je vais pas vous faire tout l'historique
parce que sinon on va pas s'entendre
mais sur les recettes moi j'ai trouvé
que c'est un peu le concours des lépines
de l'argent magique 16 milliards
d'économies uniquement sur les
migrations
uniquement sur l'immigration et tout y
passe immigration familiale asile aide
médicale d'État social version étrangers
dont le nombre est d'ailleurs très
légèrement gonflé 10% d'économie sur les
agences et opérateurs de l'État oui on
est d'accord jusque là où on coupe je
sais pas 15 milliards d'euros récupérer
sur la fraude sociale et fiscale
où on les trouve mais oui au moment où
vous mettez le programme vous nous
expliquez pas moi je peux dire des
choses comme ça mais si vous n'expliquez
pas comment vous faites et alors la
baisse la baisse unilatérale des 5
milliards de la contribution budget
européen
que vous avez essayé de réintroduire au
PLF en plus pour moi c'est un peu le
piétinement des traités européens
c'est donc une espèce de frexit mais si
tu ne dis pas son nom regardez où en
sont les Britanniques totalement sur les
dépenses et après j'en arrête là ça
dépense baisse de TVA tout va alors
qu'on a vu que ça n'avait jamais marché
que c'est inefficace en matière de
pouvoir d'achat puisqu'elles sont
reportées sur les prix d'accord elles ne
sont pas reportées sur les prix pardon
mais sur les marges la plupart du temps
vous nous avez cité l'exemple espagnol
vous avez que les enfants espagnols
finalement n'a pas fonctionné non il a
pas fonctionné dans la période
incompréhensible concernant les
retraites je vous prends l'exemple 25
ans 25 ans
quel est votre question
donc moi je veux bien vous vous êtes
comment dire le syndrome de la cravate
vous êtes bien à l'Assemblée moi ma
question est très simple quand vous
allez mettre de côté vos propositions
populiste et démagogique pour enfin
présenter un programme crédible en
matière de finance publique
tout ça pour arriver oui
c'est de reprendre de faire la leçon sur
la réforme des retraites alors que
maintenant on a appris que vous êtes
trompé de 4 milliards d'euros excusez du
peu sur les économics ça va faire parce
que vous avez compté deux fois certaines
économies là c'est la révélation de la
semaine dernière excusez-moi j'ai un peu
du mal à l'entendre là bon c'est quand
même un peu surréaliste sur l'Espagne
vous avez tort la banque centrale la
Banque nationale espagnole a reconnu que
90% de la baisse de TVA avait été un
document écrit de la banque centrale
espagnole avait été répercuté pour les
consommateurs de la même façon au
Portugal sur les économies vous parlez
d'un chiffre de 15 milliards d'euros sur
la fraude pendant toute la campagne
présidentielle pas vous mais ce qui
défendait monsieur Macron pour un
présidentiel nous ont expliqué que ce
chiffre était fantasmagorique et venait
nulle part et qu'on pouvait à peine
faire 5 milliards d'euros monsieur Attal
c'est maintenant aligné sur nos chiffres
en reconnaissant oui on peut faire 15
milliards de lutte contre la fraude pour
en fait même faire plus puisque
entre-temps appris par en commission
vous y étiez que notamment sur la TVA il
y avait déjà 25 milliards de fraudes ne
serait-ce que sur la TVA sur les traités
européens monsieur Mylène heureuse
aujourd'hui le Danemark a un énorme
rabais là Hollande a un rabais de 3
milliards d'euros l'Allemagne arabé il
n'y a plus que la France qui a pas de
rabais sur son but virgule le programme
c'est ce que vous nous dites tout va
bien il reste 2 minutes mais il reste
deux minutes
est une tradition politique de
fédéraliste européen que je le respecte
nous on est souverainiste donc c'est
normal de pas être d'accord sur la
contribution financière à l'Europe ça ne
fait pas de moi monsieur miel un free
visiteur et je ne dis pas vous que ça
fait quelqu’un qui n'est pas patriote ce
sont juste deux vis
que c'était pas sérieux ce sont juste
deux visions et vous avez dit que je
voulais sortir de l'Europe que c'était
deux visions différentes du projet
européen nous pensons que la France n'a
pas pour son argent voilà on a le droit
de le penser et au débat sur les
finances européennes j'ai tenté de
prouver qu'il y avait des programmes qui
étaient pas très pertinents mais pour
les chiffres du budget vous m'accorderez
quand même qu'on peut annoncer tous les
chiffres qu'on veut même nous à la
limite on pourrait nous le reprocher si
vous ne n'hésitez pas les mesures
exactes qui sont derrière ça ressemble
un petit peu excusez-moi de l'expression
je trouve pas d'autres mots à cet
heure-là mais ça ressemble un petit peu
à du flan moi j'aimerais qu'on parce
qu'on l'a vu c'était quand même flou sur
les retraites vous nous reprocher les 4
milliards moi j'ai surtout reproché au
corps d'avoir escamoté les 30 milliards
de recettes d'orientation
la révélé personne a parlé vous n'en
avez pas parlé voilà nous nous en avons
parlé et personne donc vous voyez on est
un peu en responsabilité sur la dette
publique quand même on s'intéresse à ça
et on voit bien que aujourd'hui ça
ressort c'est quand même assez bizarre
moi avec le Modem
je suis on a souvent des convergences en
fait même si ça vous peut-être va pas
vous plaire parce que le MoDem a
toujours été responsabilité monsieur
Beyrou avait des paroles fortes depuis
très longtemps et il ne s'est pas dédié
et par exemple on aurait pu c'est une
proposition du président Mattei qui
aurait fait président du groupe
parlementaire modem on était d'accord
sur sa proposition de taxer les
sur-rachats d'action les surdividurantes
et les surprofits manuel mais ça c'est
pas fait donc vous voyez parfois on est
d'accord sur des mesures de recettes
nouvelles ou d'économies et je pense
qu'on peut travailler si on le souhaite
tous ensemble sans et d'ailleurs le
débat est très courtois je remercie
Monsieur Mylène d'avoir choisi cette
voix je pense qu'on peut trouver des
solutions après les Français trancheront
entre deux visions qui sont souvent très
opposants c'est ce qu'ils ont fait il y
a avec un débat on se souvient très
rapidement ce que j'aimerais c'est en
dehors effectivement des annonces qui
sont faites et dans lesquelles pour moi
il y a pas de solutions qui sont amenés
derrière vous soyez vous preniez un
petit peu plus de corps parce que là
pour l'instant c'est bien de faire des
annonces c'est lisses personne peut
s'accrocher
on va rejoindre Vincent euros pour une
dernière question à Jean-Philippe Tanguy
Vincent roux ah vous êtes la formidable
on vous écoute
alors Vincent c'est tout bah question à
Jean-Philippe Tanguy puisqu'on parlait
d'écologie tout à l'heure
partagez-vous l'indignation de Marion
cotignard l'actrice dénonce la
dissolution des soulèvements de la terre
est-ce que vous partagez son alignation
et son point de vue ben non parce que
Madame Cotillard s'inding depuis son
yacht en Méditerranée géant avec
Monsieur Cannet qui doit consommer en
une heure ce que consomme un foyer
français en une année donc propose
qu'elle se met dans un canot très
protégé qui coule son yacht voilà il
fera un geste pour la planète
ce qui est facile c'est qu'on est
effectivement ces gens qui sachent une
conscience morale en polluant la planète
de telle manière que aucun autre citoyen
en France le fera donc ça suffit c'est
ridicule et soulèvement la terre qui
disent que j'avais à dire ça fait des
années des mois pardon qu'on veut les
qu'on veut les les dissoudre donc je
salue leur dissolution et j'aimerais
qu'on supprime ça viendra au bout de
lait l'avantage fiscal qu'on accorde un
certain nombre d'associations qui sont
pas loin des sous-vêtements de la terre
il faut pas pourquoi les Français paient
pour des gens qui s'infiltrent dans les
centrales nucléaires ou qui vont qui
vont démanteler des irrigations de de
courageuse agriculteurs
j'ai ma réponse
vous avez la réponse à votre question ça
a été clair ça a été direct merci
beaucoup Vincent juste un petit mot vous
croyez toujours qu'il va je droit de
gauche
Eric Zemmour qui intervenait samedi dans
le cadre d'une fête de la violette s'en
est pris violemment et l'air mais aussi
ORL en dénonçant on va dire les mantras
de Marine Le Pen nationaliste
souverainisme populisme localise et elle
se pourvoit dit-il dans le fait de dire
qu'il y a ni droite ni gauche
Zemmour a rapporté ce qu'il veut je
l'invite à considérer que son
agressivité permanente envers tout et
tout le monde semble desservir et c'est
pas parce que moi il fait de voix plus
il agressive visiblement je langage à
trouver un autre chemin mais j'en
profite pour dire parce que tout ça
n'est pas très grave que ce qui est très
grave c'est ce qui s'est passé et que
pense qu'on sera d'accord avec notre
collègue c'est les insultes antisémites
qu'il a reçu dans le train qu'il menait
vers Limoges insultantisémite qui au
lieu d'être dénoncé par la CGT que c'est
un responsable CGT ont été couverts et
défendus par Madame Binet je trouve que
la réaction collective
qu'on a qu'on a pas eu justement face
aux déclarations de ce monsieur et de
face aux déclarations de Madame Binet
sont vraiment indignes et préoccupations
collective que vous qui n'a pas eu vous
regrettez qu'il n'y ait pas le plus de
protestations
de la majorité aussi il faut le dire il
y a eu très peu de d'indignation alors
que c'est un leader de la CGT qui a
rencontré monsieur Zemmour dans le train
et qui a sur les réseaux sociaux
stigmatiser effectivement Éric Zemmour
en évoquant un voyage vers la Pologne ce
qui évidemment est une évocation
nauséabonde voilà et moi je trouve que
la réaction collective n'a pas été à la
hauteur de de cette insulte parce que
Madame malheureusement dans votre pays
il y a parfois deux poids de mesure et
sur ce sujet là je trouve ça terrifiant
que c'est pas parce que Madame Binet de
la CGT qui peut dire n'importe quoi et
qu'elle est protégée par son statut je
tiens à dire que le CRIF la dénoncé la
lycra la dénoncé c'est un nombre de
parlementaires Renaissance ont dénoncés
moi je l'ai dénoncé et au-delà de ça il
y a des médias qui l'ont fait je dis pas
mais je pense que quand même accuser une
personnalité politique qu'on soit
d'accord ou pas avec elle qui a quand
même représente en plus 7% des Français
mais même s'il représente personne et ça
devrait être condamné je trouve que j'ai
été vraiment pas d'autres mots glacé par
l'absence de de réaction à la hauteur de
ses propos absolument
ignoble les droites je reviens à ma
question initiale est dépassé
un impérium pour reprendre un mot qu'il
aime intellectuel qu'il n'a pas donc il
peut prétendre être plus dans la même
pas mal non vous fait toujours pas peur
c'est ce que vous voulez dire non moi je
le remercie d'exister parce qu'il permet
de montrer que nous ne sommes pas des
extrémistes merci beaucoup Bruno Milian
d'avoir accepté le ce débat merci
infiniment
de nous avoir fait l'honneur de votre
présence dans auditions publiques on se
retrouve bien sûr la semaine prochaine
même heure 19h30 sur Public Sénat et
LCP la chaîne de l'Assemblée nationale
bonne semaine à tous
[Musique]